i was born and grew up in denmark uh and
you know these are countries which where
the government spends taxes and spends
approximately twice the level of the
united states
and while i am very sympathetic to many
of your spending proposals especially on
the things you mentioned on early
childhood and single-payer and the like
i also know
that these are countries that heavily
tax everybody not just the rich people
middle classes they have consumption
taxes on everything of 20
so while i'm very sympathetic to what
you say my my sense is still that you
would like to spend as a scandinavian
but not taxed as one well correct we
have
the answers and
you raise some very good points
comparing the us with europe and
countries in europe would be naive
oversimplistic and offend a bunch of
people land masses are complex
but i'm going to go ahead and compare
them anyways because some of the
comparisons between europe and the us
remain way too superficial read my lips
it's not uncommon to obsess over the
usual suspects for why the u.s is less
equal than europe and also has less good
quality affordable social programs
the analysis is simple the us has more
billionaires and taxes than less europe
has less billionaires but taxes than
more need a larger tax base to fund
popular social programs and also less
inequality just raise the taxes on the
rich like the europeans do
now although the tax rates for rich
people explain some part of the
difference it doesn't explain enough
europeans can afford good social
programs because a lot of europeans pay
a lot for them mainly through indirect
taxes and europeans are also more equal
before taxes even factored in because a
lot of the social programs they pay more
for also reduce pre-tax inequality
where americans deal with a sales tax at
their final point of sale europeans deal
with a vat which is a consumption tax
that taxes at multiple steps across
entire supply chains
this means that a lot of things in
europe will be more expensive but that
public money can be redistributed
towards social programs that will reduce
before tax inequality even more
the u.s has so far been unable to adopt
the same why
well in part because taxing the
wealthiest of society is easier to
advertise and justify than taxing
everybody a lot more in europe most
people don't really need to be convinced
about paying for their welfare states
because it works sufficiently for most
of them but in the u.s there's an
intimate struggle with deciding whether
pre-distribution will be a state local
or federal solution
part of the reason is that in the u.s
the federal government gets the most
media attention while state and local
governments can avoid scrutiny this
means that minimum wage hikes in the u.s
are practically always seen as a
responsibility for the federal
government which has to delicately
balance different costs of living like
laborers living in new york city and
minors living in west virginia
in europe though a country like france
or denmark can offer different
geographically sensitive policy while
also being held more directly into
account because the assignment of
responsibility is clear to its citizens
there's this definition of a wicked
problem which is circulating around in
the literature which suggests that a
wicked problem is wicked if it has
so many dimensions to it that you can't
go at one angle to the problem and try
to fix it and i think school finances
like that so school districts get money
from their local communities in the form
of property taxes they'll also get money
from the state and the state might give
the money through multiple formulas and
then a portion a much smaller portion
about nine or ten percent comes from the
federal government so even if you try to
solve the problem at say the state level
there are these other funding sources
that come with their own restrictions
which ultimately affect how the money
gets used in schools in connecticut a
u.s state the school in bridgeport will
be poor by virtue of being surrounded by
poor properties while school in
greenwich will be richer because it is
surrounded by richer properties this is
because local taxes are largely funded
by property values in the area however
this concept fails to explain everything
educational disparities also exist
across europe and within its countries
the us is not unique for having a system
that predisposes poor children to poor
resources
education systems are complex finland is
not the same as sweden and resources
invested in education and the quality
that follows does not seem like a linear
relationship the us's unique situation
is that its quality does not match the
amount that the us actually spends on it
one of the problems with answering why
resources don't match the quality you
would expect in the us is because the
decentralized nature of school districts
makes it pretty difficult to actually
identify what spending works and what
doesn't
overall there are some indications that
compared with europe the amount of
staffing the associated health and
retirement benefits alongside
transportation all add up to more costs
for the american education system but
the differences don't end there
in the 1990s as the crime rate was
plummeting as american life was getting
safer and safer
americans freaked out and thought that
if they take their eyes off their
children the children will be abducted
now this goes back the fear was stoked
by cable tv in the 1980s there were a
few high-profile abductions but it's not
until the 1990s that we really start
locking kids up and saying you cannot be
outside until you're 14 or 15.
we took this essential period of
childhood from about 8 to 12 when kids
throughout history have practiced
independence have gotten into adventures
have made rafts and floated down the
mississippi river we took that period
and said you don't get to practice
independence until it's too late until
that period is over
kids in the u.s are raised differently
than kids in europe
some blame the planning that produced
more isolated american families some the
over paranoia towards kidnapping in the
1980s and others point to an
increasingly competitive environment
where parents try to give their children
an edge over the others by helicoptering
them
it's really not that far stretch to say
that many european children could be
considered to have more freedom at an
earlier age american children are less
likely to be able to walk to school
alone compared with european children
which you can of course connect to
overall crime rates and authoritative
school policy is still much more
accepted across the u.s than it is in
europe so
the real key to uh
the distinctiveness of america
is the structure of our government one
part of it of course is the independence
of the judiciary but there's there's
there's a lot more
there are very few countries in the
world for example that have a bicameral
legislature
oh england has a house of lords for the
time being but the house of lords has no
substantial power they can just make the
commons pass a bill a second time france
has a senate it's honorific italy has a
senate it's honorific very few countries
have two separate
bodies in the legislature equally
powerful
that's a lot of trouble as you gentlemen
doubtless know
to get the same language through two
different bodies elected in a different
fashion
very few countries in the world
have a a separately elected uh chief
executive
sometimes i go to europe to talk about
separation of powers
and when i get there i find that all i'm
talking about
is independence of the judiciary
because the europeans don't even try to
divide the two political powers the two
political branches the legislature
and the chief executive
in all of the parliamentary countries
the chief executive is the creature of
the legislature there's never any
disagreement between them and the and
the the prime minister as there is
sometimes between you and the president
when there's a disagreement they just
kick them out
they have a no-confidence vote a new
election and they get a prime minister
who agrees with the legislature
and
you know the europeans the difference is
simple european countries are mainly
nations not federations
a european state if it existed could
never be the same as the us
written in their constitution u.s states
are modeled after the federal government
and state governments which mirror the
one above usually have their own chamber
of representatives a senate and also
have an executive mirrored after their
president
in europe if there was any state that
was above the countries that made it up
it would have to be modeled from those
very different countries beneath it
rather than serving as a model for the
countries below it
this is an important difference because
it means that any kind of european
government would have to balance
parliamentary systems with presidential
republics federal states with unitary
ones and they'll be expected to create a
system that hopefully pleases each one
sufficiently
all in all although the differences
between the two are practically endless
and some are near impossible to actually
describe it's still a worthwhile effort
to try and figure a few out and also
discuss them
in some way europe has more breathing
room to understand what it wants to be
which is no easy task because whatever
you think europe is it can still look
across the atlantic and realize what it
definitely is not
[Music]
you